imagine if we were not two weeks in one
day away from a presidential election
but rather two weeks in one day away
from a threatened invasion by a foreign
cult figure of some kind imagine if that
foreign invader intended to take over
control of our government and had
already declared that when he did so he
intended to remove 11 million people who
lived here which would require putting
them first in camps and then presumably
in other countries imagine if that
foreign invader had already declared he
would upon taking control put up a wall
along one of our national borders
imagine if that foreign invader had
repeatedly praised the leadership of
such dictatorships as Russia and North
Korea and then went on national
television here in front of tens of
millions of Americans and explained that
the dictator of Syria was much tougher
and smarter than the American leaders
imagine if that foreign invader had
already declared he intended to
institute a religious test for anybody
entering into the new country and
intended to bar any members of a certain
religion from coming here and said
others coming here would have to be
granted ideological certification
imagine if that foreign invader had
already declared he would have his
troops kill the families of terrorism
suspects that he would Institute racial
profiling to find terrorism suspects and
that he would institute national
stop-and-frisk racial profiling to find
criminal suspects imagine if that
foreign invader had already made
dog-whistle threats about international
banks against members of the Jewish
faith in this country and if that
foreign invader had once reportedly kept
in a cabinet near his bed a book of the
speeches of Adolphe Hitler imagine if
that foreign invader had repeatedly
praised the leadership of such
dictatorships of North Korea and Russia
and was connected personally and by
members of his gang past and present to
the Russian dictator and imagined that
then he said that even before he
solidified control over his country he
might personally meet with the Russian
dictator imagine if that foreign invader
had asked publicly on live television
why the country he intended to take over
had nuclear weapons if it did not intend
to use those
clear weapons imagine if that foreign
invader had declared that all of our
treaties economic and military would be
abrogated or canceled or subject to
renegotiation and that our primary
military treaty NATO might apply only to
countries that paid us protection money
imagine if that foreign invader had
declared our elections raped our debates
crooked and the leaders of both of our
main parties dishonest and three times
had refused to say that the loser of the
most important of these elections was
even obligated to honor the outcome
imagine if that foreign invader had
implied groups of Americans should try
to intimidate other groups of Americans
from voting and that those Americans
with guns should act in some manner
against leaders of whom they did not
approve imagine if that foreign invader
had spent four years constantly
insisting that our foremost elected
leader was ineligible for his office and
then claimed the man was actually the
co-founder of the most heinous terrorist
group in the world imagine if that
foreign invader had already promised to
when he took over do everything he could
to put at least one of our leading
political figures in prison imagine if
that foreign invader had declared that
our freedom of the press should no
longer be protected that freedom of the
press does not include printing things
he believes are not true that he would
make it easier to sue the media that
readers should cancel subscriptions to
the newspapers that criticized him and
that even entertainment programs that
displeased him should be quote retired
imagine if that foreign invader had
questioned why a suspect in a minor
terrorism attack should be granted
access to a lawyer or access to a doctor
or access to food imagine if that
foreign invader had already declared
that our country was rife with
lawlessness and race riots especially
where the members of minority groups
live and that he was going to fix that
by whatever means were necessary imagine
if that foreign invader had declared
that some of our inner cities were more
dangerous than Afghanistan and that
drugs are a very very big factor in
protests in those areas and that those
areas were as bad
third-world country imagine if that
foreign invader had declared that
America was in a quote death spiral and
imagine if that foreign invader had
surveyed all of the problems real and
imagined of the country he intended to
take over two weeks from tomorrow and
declared I alone can fix it and then had
television statements that claimed that
he said he will protect you because he
is the only one who can imagine if all
that was what we faced two weeks from
tomorrow it truly isn't hard to do
because that is exactly what we do face
two weeks from tomorrow
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space